this is the new mark two's lab side
Cobra a car that looks just as amazing
as a vintage one but with all the modern
underpinnings it is built by a small
California company called superformance
for classic car fans this new car might
look familiar it's a reproduction of the
Shelby Cobra created in 1962 the
original Cobras were designed by Carroll
Shelby who dared to put an American Ford
v8 engine into a stylish British racing
car body he basically created what many
considered to be a perfect sports car
and driving a classic Cobra means you
can be as glamorous as Steve McQueen
Robert Redford and Paul Newman when they
drove their tiny roadsters along the
coolest beaches of the 1960s and 70s in
short these cars are icons superformance
bought the official licensing rights
from the Carroll Shelby estate so it
could mimic every detail from the
original car sold in the UK down to the
right side turning indicators tiny
rearview and side mirrors a hood that
opens opposite the front
lash lock seatbelts and dozens of
handmade knobs on the center console and
the seat backs and door are so small
that it's easy and fun to slip in and
out this new old Cobra comes with a Ford
v8 engine with 375 horsepower what it
doesn't have is power steering or power
brakes that means you really have to
crank the steering wheel as you move
around a curve and you have to press the
brakes for what feels like miles before
the car comes to a complete stop
but that's a small price to pay for
genuine pure unadulterated driving it's
something that's tough to get these days
when even the sportiest cars are
automatic everything plus your arms and
caps will be extra toned from all the
pulling and shifting the Cobra
I drove cost $100,000 but it's entry
level price is just under seventy
thousand so while I wouldn't buy this as
a first car it's perfect to keep on hand
for after-hours fun superformance says
they have built and sold about four
thousand cobras since starting
production a few years ago and delivery
time is about four months so I suggest
you get your name on the list stat